[موسيقى]
استهداف ليس الاول لكنه قاتل كان مفترضا
ان يكون مجردا مرورا بروتيني تحول الى فخ
مميت من القوات الدوليه العامله في جنوب
لبنان في المعلومات المتداوله
اتجهت عبر طريق اعتيادي في منطقه عملياتها
في جنوب لبنان
تعرضت الى حادث في بلده العاقبيه في ساعه
متاخره من ليل الاربعاء
كانت في طريقها الى مطار بيروت وعلى متنها
جنديان للمفارقه كنا عائدين الى ايرلندا
عاقبه لقيهما نبا وفاه افراد من اسرتهما
وهنا وقع الحادث والعمليه بانتظار
التحقيقات
احاطت بالاليه حشود وصفها وزير الدفاع
الايرلندي بالمعاديه وبداوا باطلاق النار
على جنود اليونيفيل ما تسبب بمقتل الجندي
ايلاندي واصابه ثلاثه رغم التفاصيل
القليله والمتضاربه وفقا اليونفيل فان
مصدرا قضائيا لبنانيا اشار الى معلومات
مهمه قد تقدم التحقيقا الذي تجريه
اليونيفيل مع الجيش اللبناني المصدر اكد
ان الاليه تتعرضت لسبع رصاصات اطلقت
باتجاه القوه التي تستقلها لكن النقطه
التي يجب التوقف عندها ان الجندي اصيب
برصاصه في الراس اي اشبه بعمليه تصفيه
مباشره
مفارقه اخرى حملتها الحادثه التي وقعت في
منطقه نفوذ حزب الله ان مسرح الجريمه يبعد
نحو خمسه كيلومترات عن العاقبيه موقع
اغتيال احد اشرس المعارضه الحزب لقمان
سليم في فبراير من العام 2021
عامل اضافي يعزز فرضيه تطورت حزب الله او
عناصر تابعه له وزير الخارجيه الايام
كوفاني قال ان ذلك لم يكن متوقعا نعم كانت
هناك توترات على الارض بين قوات حزب الله
واليونيفيل في الاشهر الاخيره الا ان
ميليشيا حزب الله بنفسها عن الحادثه
وعادتها الى سكان المحليين وصفه اياها
بالحادث غير المقصود وان الحسبه غير ضالع
فيه لكن الشقوق القائمه والاسئله كذلك في
منطقه لا يتحرك او يتحرك فيها شيء دون علم
حزب الله او بايعازه